A new thin film of quantum dots covers glass
and transforms windows into solar panels.
The dots have a lifespan of 14 years and right
now they’re trying to raise their energy
conversion efficiency from 1.9% to a more
practical 6%.
And Kengoro is a biohumanoid robot from the
University of Tokyo that cools itself by sweating.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Kernel is developing a memory prosthesis.
The new company has invested $100 million
to further over two decades of neuroprosthetic
research by biomedical engineer Theodore Berger.
While company founder Bryan Johnson has longterm
science fiction goals like the ability to
download knowledge or exchange memories, the
current plan is to help people suffering from
memory disorders.
For instance, using an algorithm to instruct
electrodes involved in longterm memory to
restore the circuitry in people suffering
from Alzheimer's.
Boosting brains to learn a thousand times
faster would happen sometime down the road.
A new hybrid power fabric uses solar as well
as mechanical movement to harness power.
Solar cells are made into micro-cable structures
and woven with nanogenerators to create the
smart fabric.
Not only does it charge using ambient light
but the mechanical movement allows wind and
human motion to gather energy.
And researchers from the Georgie Institute
of Technology say the fabric could be used
in tents, wearable garments like scarves or
curtains.
Navdy is like projecting your smartphone onto
your windshield.
The headup display is the world’s first
augmented driving device that allows GPS navigation
and phone access without taking your eyes
off the road.
The steering wheel dial allows for scrolling
through or skipping songs and zooming in and
out of the map while gesture controls handle
accepting and dismissing phone calls.
And after beginning pre-orders two years ago
they just started shipping this week.
A brain implant allows you to feel with a
robotic hand.
Neuroengineers at the University Of Pittsburg
used magnetic resonance imaging to map the
regions of the patient’s brain associated
with imagining a touch on different parts
of the hand.
After getting used to the system the patient
could recognize the location of the touches
on a robotic hand with 100 percent accuracy
but it’s still very early on in its proof
of principle stage.
Sundrop is the world’s first farm growing
vegetables in the desert using seawater.
15,000 tonnes of tomatoes a year are now being
grown Australia using 23,000 mirrors that
generate solar power and seawater from the
Spencer Gulf.
The solar power is used to desalinate or remove
the salt from the seawater to create freshwater
for the crops.
They’re now planning to create these farms
in Portugal and the United States.
These E-paper displays are like reusable digital
post-it notes.
Microsoft Research developed the display to
run on office lights using a solar panel on
the back.
It can communicate with other e-paper displays
via bluetooth, they can be updated with an
app and have a sticky back to attach to stuff
easily.
Right now this is just a prototype and isn’t
commercially available.
Yet.
Drones can be charged in mid-air using technology
from Nikola Tesla.
Scientists from Imperial College London use
inductive coupling, demonstrated by Tesla,
which allows for wireless exchange of power
between copper coils.
They’re about a year away from making this
commercially available and say that this technology
could also be used in healthcare devices as
well as interplanetary missions.
Finally, Stanford engineers have developed
gecko-inspired grippers to grab and move space
debris.
I’ve learned from gecko lizards to make
small adhesive grippers that adhere to smooth
surfaces such as solar panels and fuel tanks
with really little attachment and detachment
effort.
Similar functions have been achieved with
the curved gripper.
Little attachment force, strong grip and clean
detachment.
I’m gonna leave you with a body movement
activated mid-air display - and as always
- thanks for watching.
There are those who say today that opportunities
have ceased to exist.
Things are finished.
We have everything and not enough.
For years, the oilmen cursed gasoline.
It was a troublesome byproduct and they dumped
millions of gallons of it into the rivers
and streams.
Then, science discovered that gasoline was
liquid horsepower.
In any one of thousands of test tubes of today
there may be a million job opportunities for
tomorrow.
And the industrial scientists and engineers
are the pioneers of present day America.
The creators of progress.
Of new industries and new jobs.
It’s a bewildering future alright, not because
there are no new frontiers but progress.
Hey I have a couple of really cool announcements
- first of all I made a series with Google
Arts & Culture channel called Hyper History.
It’s a super quick look at really fascinating
things throughout history including topics
from Duck-Billed Platypuses to The Missing
Link.
So click here or the click the link at the
top of this video’s description to watch
all five episodes.
That’s five more episodes of me talking
about stuff that you should really check out.
Also, Curiosity Box #1 is almost gone forever.
Hang on.
It’s heavy because it’s full of awesome,
great stuff.
But like I said there’s only a couple of
days left to go until this baby is gone forever
and you can no longer get all of the exclusive
items available like this great Vsauce T-shirt
of a deepsea diver climbing a tree pointing
at the Vsauce constellation.
This actually glows in the dark.
It’s ridiculously cool.
So if you want to get in on the ground floor
of The Curiosity Box you have to order
right now.
Okay?
Like, right now.
Like, CuriosityBox.com.
You have to go there and order right now.
After I say the word now.
Now.